foreign
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
I say it's water and I do not appreciate
being called a liar on my own stream
ah
refreshing
uh
hope everybody's doing well hope uh the
start of October is treating you all
right
um
I hope your September was better than
mine was because my September was
loaded with
nonsense so it's nice to uh to come here
and unwind a bit
ah
happy Yom Gabor oh is it that or is it
that early this year
hmm
uh or maybe or maybe I'm confusing with
other stuff I can never I like I can't
even keep track of the holidays that are
like traditional like I completely
forgot that Monday is indigenous
people's day in Vermont until I got uh
an alert from the school that reminder
your kid doesn't have school on Monday
like ah right okay
oh yours too homebody yeah yeah that
that kind of uh that kind of sums it up
you're sure mine was better than yours
Diana look I'm not here to compare I'm
not I'm not looking to do the uh the
misery Olympics but I I think uh
the general impression I've gotten is
lots of people had a
September comparable or Worse to mine
yes okay so yeah if we were competing
Diana you do win
so yeah
how am I I'm I'm all right I've had a
pretty productive day uh did a lot of
shooting I've Caroline already knows
this I've um I've kind of I've
changed how I'm approaching my work week
and I now kind of have dedicated days
like yesterday was my uh watching day
where like the stuff that I mean stuff
that comes out on a day that I'm trying
to turn around right away like with
She-Hulk or whatever that's when it
comes out but like I've got stuff that I
need to watch for upcoming planned
videos stuff that I need to watch for
reviews and so you know a day that what
you're doing today is working your way
through the stuff you're supposed to be
watching and today was a shooting day
um so I shot a number of videos today uh
for both I say both four uh it's for
more than two things but for the Vera
wild channel for the Council of Geeks
channel for the break room and also for
you know that other
that other site I have stuff on
you know the one
uh
no we're not doing for Yorkshire man
style misery comparison I like that
sketch actually I like that
I like that sketch a lot
right
I used to have to get up in the morning
at 10 o'clock at night half an hour
before I went to bed
drink a cup of sulfuric acid
work 27 hours a day down at the down at
the middle and pay the owner for
permission to come to work and when we
got home a guy would come along and kill
us and down to about on our grave
singing Hallelujah
you try and tell the young people of
today that they won't believe you
uh sorry Monty Python moment
um yeah
uh no misery Olympics but I am in the
crowd that is happy to see September
gone don't miss it yeah same
same
uh
yes yes Carwin I am indeed quite the
spicy accountant
spicy
what are my thoughts on South Park
Binger longer and uncut I have not
watched it in years my memory is that it
was better than almost any episode of
the show clearly a lot of thought went
into it and it had a
um it had a lot of foresight because it
basically
preemptively parodied the criticisms it
knew it was going to get
so as there's some fun meta stuff going
on there if you think about it actually
uh
but uh yeah I gotta
oh sorry sorry if this schemes anybody
but the ah
the Lash was poking the corner of my eye
and I've had them in for a while so I
don't know why it only just started
bugging me it could be that like I'm I'm
out of kind of Hardcore work mode and
like maybe I was not noticing it because
I was powering through it and focused on
other stuff but that was that was really
starting to get to me ah so apologies if
that skeeved anybody
um but those those those had to come off
ah
uh anybody seen Bros I have no interest
in Bros like I have very little interest
in romantic comedy at all so it has
nothing to do with the fact that it's
all guys it's just I watched the trailer
and it just reminded me of every reason
why I don't watch romantic comedies
99.99999 of the time
uh
Liz breaking Vera with Riverdale gives
me life I I will get that video restored
later this week I hadn't realized that
it accidentally looped back in on itself
I I need to fix that and get back to it
I'll do that tomorrow because
um tomorrow in terms of how I'm working
my work week now tomorrow
um after
um the twitch stream is an editing day
so I'll get I'll get that sorted and try
and get that back up tomorrow
I prefer the glue on individual lashes
that stay on for a few days ever try
them no the idea of trying to place
individual lashes just the concept of
that already gives me anxiety
because like it took me
it took me a good decade to get good
putting this on and these because of how
long they are and how exaggerated they
are are very forgiving the more
naturalistic they look the less
forgiving they are to apply the idea of
doing individual that hard no hard no
for me no interest like if I went for
like a spa treatment and somebody else
wanted to put that crap on me and I just
had to lay there with my eyes closed
while they did it maybe that but not
doing it to myself John vinyls thank you
so very much for
um for the Super Chat that's a generous
one too the Virgin Duffer Brothers
stopping their episode for 60 minutes to
have vecna info dump his backstory
versus the Chad Dana Terence telling
Bella's entire life story with nothing
but background paintings
I hadn't thought to compare
stranger things to Owl House
but yes
very much yes
it's frustrating like I'm not
necessarily frustrated that people liked
stranger things season four honestly I'm
glad if they did I want people to like
things more than I do if I don't like
them
but I prefer to understand it and I
don't
I don't understand like
let me put it this way excuse me
if you enjoy vechna as a villain then
what you enjoy about stranger things as
an overall product is distinctly
different from what I enjoyed about it
because to me vekna is antithetical to
huge swaths of what I liked about
stranger things so if you for anyone who
liked vechna I'm happy for you but I
don't get it because it means you were
on board for Four Seasons for a show and
enjoying it as I was enjoying it but
enjoying it for different reasons
apparently
um like the one thing I'll give credit
the vechna's mo the way he operates is
interesting and works pretty well but
him as a character he's awful he's
really terrible I hate him he's right up
there with vicious for
um
for villains that I just feel dragged
the entire proceedings down
I do knit lace so I I guess fussy
individual lashes are no biggie well
yeah like for some people that's not a
problem at all like for me that like no
that idea just does nothing
um but make me go ah
uh when Americans watch that sketch do
they get the like British cultural
aspects of it like a big part of his
Yorkshire people being known for being
slightly slow talking and depressive
um short answer to that is no
um generally for American audiences if
they connect with it it's either because
there's something about it that also
Rings true to an American Experience in
our case just the general practice of
kind of being like you think you had it
tough well you think you had it tough
and for an American audience with
something like the four Yorkshire man
sketch it is detached from its specific
cultural context but that is something
that we also have over here
um that just doesn't it lacks some of
the specific signifiers it's tied to
um that get lost in translation but the
core of it is something we've got that
here too so I suspect that's true of
like a lot of British comedy that does
actually travel is that while they're my
British entertainment in general that is
able to travel while there might be a
lot of things that are very specific to
the UK
there is also something else either
underneath or alongside or built into
that that applies elsewhere that
elsewhere is able to latch on to and
have fun with
am I in any way excited for the Mario
movie
as a curiosity and honestly the image
they released the poster like that had
zero impact on any opinion I had I was
like okay
unless something other than the poster
came out because also was the poster
where you see him from behind I'm like
okay it's a lot it's very detailed I
guess he told the point of are they are
they losing kind of the cartoonishness
but like whatever I have I have no
emotional investment in the Mario movie
I like your earrings thank you friend of
mine made these uh Liz got them for me
but a friend of ours
um uh
uh Tiana who performs burlesque as
Dominique Anjou
uh they made these and yeah and I like
these a lot they're heavy I can't wear
them for too too long
um but I do enjoy them
uh the US context is the whole walked up
hills Barefoot to school in the snow
both ways think yeah yeah that that
that's pretty much how Americans will
connect with that with that sketch
um this is the first live stream of
yours I'm on since they came out as MB
ah that's that's great Rowan I'm I'm
really glad you were able to do that I'd
like genuinely
I'm really happy for you
the poster looked good for illumination
I mean illumination for me isn't even
bad the illumination is the is the
epitome of mid
they are the midst mid of mid
Animation Studios
yeah I just I'm trying to think if there
was anything they did that made me go oh
yeah that because I don't think there
was like even Blue Sky which was another
Super mid uh one before Disney bought it
and shut it down well it came as part of
the foxy on Disney shut it down like at
least they had the Peanuts movie which
was great but yeah illumination's just
super mid
Germany as if for Yorkshire men were a
whole country
[Laughter]
why are we why have we got Waluigi in
chat
Wang wow Luigi I actually don't know how
he sounds Beyond just the way I know
that that's about all I've got
regarding stranger things my favorite
thing about the series is the
relationship between Steve and the kids
and the friendship between Steve and
Robin those are right up there I love
Steve
starting season two because like you're
not really supposed to like him in
season one but starting season two Steve
is easily one of my favorite things
about it
he kind of saves season two for me if
I'm being honest October recent horror
decoration candy Halloween cookies cakes
um so like
um I have some friends who are working
on uh they're talking about possibly
putting together like a watch along for
horror movies we'll see if anything
happens with that
um I've got some decoration like I've
got some general fall stuff up like some
like a fall wreath on the door
um I've got a Dracula wins a very corny
Dracula windsock
up but that's kind of it for now uh
pumpkin carving will happen later in the
month
um
Halloween cookies and cakes that's
that's new to me I'm not familiar
uh I've been watching some videos on
Lost media because it's so intriguing
like did you know some people found some
stuff from the Lost Chris Farley version
of Shrek I know I had heard I'd heard
some of the audio from that
um and I think it was even paired with
[Music]
um
storyboards I think I'd heard that yeah
heard some of it
I love the way you impersonated Mario on
your live stream
oh
October is corn maze time I did my time
in the corn maze this year already I'm
not doing it again
uh horror movies oh the thing is Bruce
like
I like to think
there is a horror or horror adjacent
movie for everybody
now maybe you don't like to actually be
scared oh yes thank you Carolyn I will
just one second let me finish I'll I'll
finish the thought I've got and I will
do that
um
if you are not actually into being
scared there are can't be horror movies
there are animated movies that have
monsters but aren't scary there are
things like Guillermo del Toro that are
atmospheric but are usually about
something other than scaring you whether
it be about the connections between the
characters or you know a specific
character's Journey or what have you or
just something that deals in horror
imagery but isn't necessarily a horror I
feel like there's something out there
for pretty much everybody that at least
has horror aesthetic if not actually
being horror I think that's honestly I
think that's part of what Tim Burton's
appeal was especially when he first
excuse me uh got really big
late 80s early 90s because he brought a
Gothic aesthetic
without trying to scare you
like you look at Beetlejuice Beetle just
not scary but it's very Gothic it's
drenched in bizarre and Macabre imagery
similarly with The Addams Family around
the same time which wasn't burden but
still I I think that's part of the
appeal of some of some of the stuff like
that so yes okay
um because Carowinds remind me next live
stream so two weeks from today
we're going to be doing something a
little different something I haven't
done in almost two years
we're going to do a watch along now to
be clear this is not going to be a live
reaction there is not going to be any
image of the thing I'm watching up on
the screen or any of the audio because
that'll get the stream taken down for
copyright violation but
we're gonna watch a movie that is easily
available on Netflix and we will try and
time it and sync it up so that uh you
know we all start at the same time and
then we'll watch collectively the chat
uh can Riff on it I will Riff on it live
and the movie that we are going to do
and it is on Netflix is going to be
morbius
it's got oh it's gonna be bad but fun
that's my hope last time I did this it
was Howard the Duck and the uh the
directive video Captain America so this
stuff's fun and it's been a while
because I did that uh I did that
actually on Election night 2020.
desperately uh to do anything other than
focus on the election and to avoid the
news so yeah we're kind we're kind of
doing that again
um but this time uh for the uh for the
Halloween season and we're gonna do
morbius it's gonna be bad it's gonna be
fun and I am gonna hydrate to get
through it I'm sure
uh already a watch list for upcoming
Halloween I'm saving Hocus Pocus 2 and
Wednesday series uh hoping it is not too
big a letdown
I unless he commissions me I don't have
plans to watch Hocus Pocus too unless
like either that happens or I'm with
people who really want to see it like I
won't shut it down but I have no real
interest
um the Wednesday series I don't know I
might give it an episode I'll tell you
what I'm looking forward to
because I have Hulu now uh I am looking
forward to Hellraiser
um I'm here for that to see how that to
see how that comes because like we have
not had a good Hellraiser movie in
oh God forever
it's been forever and like
it's it's so good and just I
I have such sights to show you
oh
anyways
uh oh Michael Anderson Doyle thank you
Dharma
uh oh 11 month membership
uh uh six weeks on HRT five billion
reasons to Rejoice being a rabble Rouser
one gender fluid trans person who is
grateful
thank you Dharma thank you very much I
appreciate that
uh
uh wait I already went into corn maze
this month yeah so
uh two two months ago I think it was I
think it was in August yeah it was in
August
um so there's a corn maze not too far
from where I live it's actually the
largest corn maze
definitely in New England might be the
largest corn maze in the country
but it's definitely the largest corn
maze in New England
and it had already been set up you know
as amazing everything else but they do a
one day LARPing event set in the Maze
and I took the kiddo and we did that and
that's that was actually much better
than the standard corn maze because oh
geez excuse me sorry
um standard corn maze like
it just gets frustrating after a while
and succeeding out of corn maze is is
kind of an absolute like either you get
through to the end
or you don't you know you bail and take
one of the emergency exit paths that
takes you straight out you either
succeed or you don't there is no middle
ground
but what was really cool about the
LARPing events that they had which you
gave was a one day thing was that there
were all these other little things for
you to do as you went through it there
were things to collect there were
hazards to avoid there were things to
trade with other players so ultimately
after about two and a half hours kiddo's
feet were hurting and we did bail
um actually it was close to three hours
ultimately we did bail but we still felt
accomplished because we'd found three
out of four magic stones and we had
avoided the Reapers the whole time and
we still felt accomplished so like I
would go again to that event in the corn
maze I would not just do it straight up
corn maze again
I don't think ever
but that format worked really well I
enjoyed that have I seen a Hocus Pocus
too nope don't currently plan to
I'd like I just I just I don't have
Nostalgia for the original I just
I just don't
Crimson Peak Suspiria the crow Crimson
Peak is good the Crow's good I have not
seen Suspiria either version
um
another piece of lost media recently
found out uh is quantum Quest a Cassini
Space Odyssey aka the NASA produced
animated flick with basically who's who
of geek of geek culture huh
it's interesting when that stuff crops
back up the election stream was
legendary ah I'm glad people
um people enjoyed that
it's morbidden time
favorite part is when he just morbs all
over everybody
uh
uh remember when Howard the Duck
couldn't pay his bill yeah no I'm not
reading the rest of those pawns I'm not
doing it uh do you think there needs to
be more horror themed animated shows
something like coward the cover
Ed the courageally dog hmm
Courage the Cowardly Dog
um
I don't know because like there is stuff
out there that's for kids that dips into
um scarier imagery like I would argue
that by its second season Gravity Falls
did that the owl house did that
[Music]
um
I'm not sure if there's been another
show that like was intended by its
nature to be about those things
um in recent years but there's
definitely plenty of stuff that borrow
some
scary and unnerving stuff and do it
really well
of course I keep referencing Gravity
Falls as if it's recent it's really not
at this point which is so weird Supreme
Omega thank you so very much for the
Super Chat do you feel Killing Joke and
death in the family created issues with
the joker because later writers kept
upping the Joker's brutality
to the points of excess
um
that's one of those things where
do you blame
the origin point
for the creators who came later who
didn't know how to handle the same thing
or appreciate the Restraint of not doing
that all the time
and I honestly don't have an answer to
that so like to make a non-comic book
comparison like
I don't
necessarily blame
um Paul Greengrass and the way he shot
the Bourne movies he made for how many
bad shaky cam action scenes
um came in the wake of that because he
was one of the few who could do it
pretty well for the most part I still
don't like it as a style but he did
about as well as it could be done and
then others imitated it and just it was
awful is that his fault that they
imitated without understanding why it
worked before and I feel similarly about
death in the family and the killing joke
I don't think the problem is those
stories I think the problem is a writing
and editorial staff who failed to
appreciate
um the fact that those things felt
momentous because they were atypical of
what the joke they were moments that
made you go oh crap he really is
dangerous
but if you make that the new Norm then
that's not special and then you get into
the needless one-upping of the brutality
but I think what I what I would rather
have been embraced was the idea of
allowing the Joker to go back to sillier
stuff
so with the idea being not he's this
dangerous and he's this dangerous all
the time but that he could become that
dangerous on a dime and immediately
things go from he's pulling some wacky
heist with gimmick weapons
to he has left a body count behind
because he's that unpredictable they may
they too many writers took the things
done in things like the killing joke and
death in the family it made it the new
normal and made the Joker predictable
those things when they happen made the
Joker unpredictable again after he had
been kind of a gimmick villain for a
while
and but then when that became the norm
he's now predictable again he's just
gonna show up and kill people that's
what he always does now the fact that he
could ping pong back and forth is to me
what would make the character compelling
but nobody seems to want to do that
he took the child into the corn did
Stephen King teach you nothing I've said
before I haven't read Stephen King but
uh appreciated nonetheless
ah let's see do I watch Bridgerton nope
uh not my not my uh cup of tea
uh
you don't decorate cookies look like bat
pumpkins and ghosts also store-bought
Pillsbury cookies with pumpkins and
ghosts and Little Debbie's Halloween
themed cakes like I'm familiar with the
concept but that no that was never part
of my traditions the Christmas is when
you make themed cookies in for me for my
family
ah
I thought I'd never hear you say it's
morbid time uh
uh they're also fond of varying the
Sesame Street with Margaret Hamilton as
the witch it went unaired after months
and dads after moms and dads were
concerned their kids had nightmares
about her
overprotective parents good grief
um you know you can beat any maze
eventually by just following one wall
endlessly not true
that is how you can beat most
mazes
the guy who designs the maze is around
where I live which as I said biggest
corn maze in New England possibly
biggest one in the country he takes what
he does
very seriously and he deliberately
designs his mazes to not be solvable by
the standard tricks
so
that is true of 99 of Mazes that is not
true of the mazes that are made in
Danville Vermont
yeah
yeah
so
he knows what he's doing
he really does
have I seen Hotel Transylvania I've seen
the first
three I barely remember the second one
at all I enjoy the energy of them I
don't particularly like the
um
overly juvenile sense of humor so I'm
I'm very
I appreciate that they exist I don't
love them
I never got the morbius jokes
I feel like Joe Pesci how is it funny
seriously Logan I mean like it mostly
was the fact that everyone could tell
from trailers it was a terrible movie
and so they just meme the heck out of it
what was really funny about that to me
was that
um Sony Sony saw the memes go crazy and
thought Oh people would with it being so
memed if we put it back in theaters
people will watch it no
no
that was that was quite funny
sadly I have to leave to go to a fun
group of pan for pansexual people now
ooh well enjoy try and catch the replay
of the stream later see if you answered
my questions ah have a good time
enjoy the pansexual party do I bake not
often not often at all on occasion not
often I I prefer cooking to baking uh
cooking's on art baking is a science you
have to be very precise with baking and
I like to wing it
uh
what if it was Anthony who sent you to
the corn maze I don't get that reference
so
um you should do a watch along with 70s
Paul Lind Halloween special has Margaret
Hamilton Donnie and Marie quality I
don't even know what that's on so like
part of the reason I decided to do
morbius is being on Netflix
um most people will have access to it
not everybody I do understand that but
there's there's nothing I can do to make
something truly universally available
but
um I don't know where one would find
that
what am I dressing up as I don't know
yet I need to ask my kiddo if she cares
and if she wants me to go all out or if
she'll be okay with me just throwing
something something together I've
usually just thrown something something
together like you know put on a black
coat in one of my sets of horns kind of
thing because like I'm I'm not there to
distract from whatever she's doing
do people enjoy trying to get out of a
maze some do
uh my experience of it when there wasn't
the LARPing event going on was that it's
it's very tedious
ah
uh the guy who runs the corn maze where
I live has a Burmese Bernie's mountain
dog named Lucy oh that's cute that's
sweet
uh let's see
what I consider a Nightmare Before
Christmas a Halloween or Christmas movie
It's both
it's both
like I don't I don't know why it has to
be either or
I'm just being silly Vera I I figured
you were a homebody but like some
something went over my head what
whatever
do whatever Anthony was supposed to mean
to me it went over my head and maybe
it's something that if you were
explaining to me I would go oh but like
it in the moment right now
I don't have Netflix but I can get
access to more BS I reckon
I reckon you can
I couldn't decide this year ended up
getting a headband with horns and a
corset so I'm going as a demon nice
always a good option
uh you can go out as Beast from Beauty
and the Beast I cannot if I was gonna do
Beast from Beauty and the Beast I'd want
to do it properly and that would mean
effectively a freaking fursuit and I'm
not doing that
uh
uh shouldn't I dress as yellow diamond
boy that
like if I were trying to match my
kiddo's outfit
um that would be something that would
make a lot of sense but like I'm I have
neither the time the means Northern
funds to put that together
I'd oh okay hang on I am on an off
chance gonna check something real quick
just because I need to know that this
is not an easily available thing
yeah there isn't uh there isn't like a
freely available
like pre-made yellow diamond costume I'd
have to get something custom yeah that's
not happening
anyways moving on from that
uh that would have been funny that would
have been very funny if I could have
pulled that together but like
realistically I can't Anthony was the
kid from was the kid with horrifying
wepers
horrifying Powers wepers how did I even
get there
in that Twilight Zone episode
oh okay yeah I didn't pick up on that
um something I found out recently is to
my knowledge Venom is Marvel's first
bisexual anti-hero which makes sense
because he's a sentient group alien if
I'm wrong correct me so
it I
I don't
know I don't know that's the first time
hearing about that so my first question
is when you say Venom do you mean the
combination of character in symbiote or
are you talking about just the Symbiote
as an entity unto itself
because I
think the Symbiote is not gendered
um and certainly if you are considering
the bonding to a human host as an
equivalent to sex then yes it would be
non-discriminatory in terms of sexual
preference but that all feels coded
um and so I don't my short answer to
that is I don't know
thank you
how do we feel about lesbian Velma
it's about damn time
seriously like we've all known for
goodness sake we've all known you could
go as Belle from Beauty and the Beast
you'd Rock the Gown see the thing is I
would much rather wear her her blue and
white dress from the opening than where
the yellow ball gown
I have a stevonnie costume but it
definitely wouldn't fit you I'm
yeah I'm sure it wouldn't
uh what do I think of Billy eckner in
his movie Bros Billy Eichner is just
someone who has never had appeal to me
um the little like this may what I'm
about to say may be unrepresentative
because I haven't watched a lot of stuff
but the impression I've gotten from the
tiny Snippets of Billy on the Street is
that he is famous for being
um flamboyant and loud
and that's
I don't care
[Laughter]
I'm sure he's a perfectly nice guy maybe
there's more to him than that but that's
that's what's been fed to me through
osmosis
a flamboyant and loud
okay
go about your day I'll go about mine
underrated uh Halloween movie shows and
specials
the Halloween episodes of Roseanne
the original run of Roseanne were really
good
those were really good because they were
always trying to one-up each other with
the costumes or pranking each other
those are good episodes and I feel like
those are forgotten partial partially
because like we've tried to scrub
Roseanne from Collective memory which
Fair those are still good episodes
though
the Symbiote okay see like I know the
symmet is referred to as he I don't know
if the Symbiote is actually definitively
gendered in the first place
again I feel like I'd have to really dig
into lore for that
just gonna wear my reindeer ones onesie
again whatever works for you
we knew it back in the 70s little kids
damn it yeah like Velma we've always
known about Vel
like that's that's not news
The Little Mermaid is it another big fat
why I mean my response to literally
every single one of these live-action
remakes has been why
I don't understand why any of them exist
so
like I'm not gonna crap all over it
because you know the the change in the
casting has clearly been meaningful for
some people especially some young
audiences and I wouldn't want to take
that away from him but from them but me
as an audience member I just I don't
care
just and it doesn't matter who you cast
as anybody doesn't matter who you cast
his aerial doesn't matter who you cast
as Ursula I just I don't why
that's me but like I don't feel so
strongly about it I'm like it shouldn't
exist I do kind of wish that they had
stopped doing this but like
look if you get something out of it fine
I just I don't get it at all
uh
do you think you'll ever get around to
do to doing overdue classic Who
reactions all right two-part answer to
that
I am going to do more overdue uh classic
who I've got one planned to do this
month and next month actually
um and then after that I'm gonna start
bringing back hopefully uh the uh voting
on The patreon to decide what ones I do
uh excuse me after that and make it a
regular feature again
um they are going to be reviews not
reaction I've had a number of people
asking me about
doing reaction content and I'm not going
to start doing that for anything other
than trailers because it a is a big pain
in the ass
to edit especially trying to get around
copyright issues it's a completely
different editing flow from anything I
do so I'd be kind of almost feel like
I'm starting from scratch from it and
for it to be interesting I it would
honestly damage my ability to enjoy
things on first viewing because I feel
like I have to play to the camera which
means that you know my my ability to
view things is already at least slightly
tainted by the fact that I look at them
through a critical lens almost
everything I see I think well I'm gonna
do a video on this later what's my
critical view of this so I've already
got that going for me and if I start
doing reactions on top of that that
means that in real time part of my brain
is is syncing
um thinking time and processing power
into remember to play to the camera oh
that's something you should make a joke
or a gag out of because you need to play
to the camera and like that that's not
how I want to experience media it's just
not I'll do it for trailers because
they're super short and on rare
occasions I will do it with something
that I know is garbage because I don't
care if I have a lousy viewing
experience of it that's why I'm willing
to do it with morbius uh for the watch
along in two weeks
the beast real name is Adam I'm aware
um oh John vinyls a thank you very very
much
meant to ask you this back in September
but I've been wondering about the
question of why hoodie king and the
Planters work so much better than better
than say uh gergy or the Gargoyles and
Hunchback of Notre Dame
um well I would say first of all they
are better integrated into the setting
that they appear in they are not a
complete Clash because in something like
amphibia or the Owl House very least at
the beginning of both of those series
there is an awful lot of Whimsy and
light-heartedness and so they play into
that and then as things get darker they
get to be an anchoring point and a way
for you to remember why it's worth
fighting to Against The Darkness because
they almost are kind of a walking
representation of what it is you're
fighting for because they remind you of
the fun and the light and The Whimsy
gergy and the Gargoyles and Hunchback of
Notre Dame just have no business being
there
they don't match the tone even at the
time that they come in they frequently
clash with it and they are detrimental
to the experience they feel plastered on
after the fact like a story was created
and then somebody went we need a comedy
sidekick and then shoved it in whereas
hoodie king and the Planters feel like
the story was built around their
inclusion so they have a place there
where these equivalents and these other
things they just they don't have a place
there it's not it's like no there's just
no reason for you to be here
should Doctor Who do a Halloween themed
episode we had Christmas New Year and
Easter already well technically they did
because it was it was the the kickoff to
flux it was the Halloween was it the
Halloween apocalypse it's the Halloween
something
so like they have actually done it
um I don't I'd like my first question is
is Halloween as big a thing
um in the UK as it is in the US because
it's it's huge here
um it's one of the big holidays here I
don't is it over there I mean that's my
first like I legitimately don't know
Supreme
Omega back again with the Super Chat
thank you in 90s Marvel I wonder why it
became difficult to evolve these
characters when they reached their 30th
anniversary is it because they became
iconic IP
um
that probably didn't help
because when you hit something like a
30-year mark
the idea of honoring that Legacy is
going to start to weigh on you
um and yeah I think that that
I think what you saw in the 90s was you
saw a fair amount of people who seem to
be held back or bogged down by the
legacy of the characters that they were
working on or they were trying way too
hard to to evolve past or reshape that
Legacy which unfortunately lent into
some of the other bad instincts of the
90s you know 90s extreme
uh so
yeah I think especially with Marvel
since so many characters kicked off in
the 60s they were all coming up on 30th
year anniversaries in the 90s I think
that probably that probably didn't help
and in like in multiple directions you
had you had some like Thor who were
being completely reworked in ways that
like why would you do that you had
others who seem to be stuck in Loops um
like Spider-Man was yeah I wouldn't be
shocked if that wasn't at least a
contributing factor
Luke tonkinson
thank you kindly
hey Vera it's been a while a long while
since I've been able to financially
support the channel I appreciate it that
you can but things are a bit better now
so have a drink or whatever you want on
me
salute
I saw your if your favorite I saw your
favorite doctors video I just found it
funny that my parents favorite doctors
were switched
um
my mother is perjuring my dad's Whitaker
yeah so yeah the short that I put up
today that that is funny
uh The Lion King is among my top three
favorite movies and it means so much to
me but the Remake is on my list of very
few things I wish could be a race from
existence like that that one is baffling
especially this is like
all this technical work
in service of what
I don't know
255 A.D thank you very much for the
Super Chat I just had an important
Revelation like literally just now is
I'm good at acknowledging my flaws
without correcting them because my
autistic uh because of my autistic
preference for habit not that you should
care well honestly I do care insofar as
I think
that self self reflection and an
understanding of how you work as a
person especially how your brain works
is important for anyone to have
so I care to that extent that I'm glad
you are coming to a better understanding
because
My Life
um has gone a lot better you know as
I've gotten just better able to work
with my ADHD rather than work against it
and a big part of that was no longer you
know working a day job for a company who
demanded certain hours and certain
things in certain timelines and to be
done a certain way regardless of how my
brain was prepared to work Be My Own
Boss does help a lot but like part of
why I'm able to do what I do for a
living and do it reliably and combat
things like burnout is I I know how to
work with my own brain
that's honestly that kind of matters a
lot
I never liked Roseanne Barr see the
thing is Roseanne herself was probably
the least funny thing about that
original show still good the original
one well before the final season good
God uh not suggesting this for this
channel but the Babylon 5 podcast is
nice balance of uh post-reaction and
talk through uh and criticism I mean
that's easier to do
because I have Jesse to bounce off of
um so like the the overall environment
of that is maybe a bit more reaction it
probably helps that again partially just
because of how my brain works I've
usually watched the episode we've talked
about she usually watched it a couple
days ago I usually watched it literally
minutes before we before we start
recording so
who's worse the Gargoyles from Hunchback
of Notre Dame or gergy I'm actually not
in a position to say
because I still haven't watched
Hunchback of Notre Dame
it's one of a couple Disney Renaissance
movies I still haven't seen
um so
I can't actually name that so right now
it's gergy by default
I don't know much about Roseanne or
sitcoms in general what are Halloween
specials like Okay so
how Roseanne did did the Halloween
episodes on that show
was
um
the I mean the way the way a lot of
sitcoms do so there are generally two
ways to do a Halloween special
you either have it the Halloween in
universe and
um and it's just about the holiday kind
of like a Christmas special but about a
different holiday and so you know you
know the whatever the Halloween
Traditions are and people dress up and
yada yada uh or well and or because
often often if you do the second one
you're also doing the first but the
other thing to do is to legitimately try
and make a scary episode of a show that
is not normally scary
and those are kind of the two ways they
usually go and even in in the latter
case it's usually still like Halloween
the day canonically
um but what Roseanne did is it was it so
it was Halloween which opened it was
Halloween in Universe
um the days the the holiday the holiday
would match and the characters in it
were always desperately trying to come
up with more outlandish and more bizarre
costumes every year and they were always
trying to scare each other one way or
another uh in particular it was it was
the two adults it was it was Roseanne
and it was Dan
um that's John Goodman's character
and they just you know they didn't do
too much to try and scare the kids maybe
a little bit but not too much but it was
mostly the two of them and like it was
an intentional war that they always went
through
um it was just good it like it embraced
the absurdity but also the Macabre
aesthetic of it all it was good it was
good stuff
uh 255 A.D again thank you very much uh
so you know when the right talks about
stuff like queer Superman to distract
from real real issues does responding to
them do more harm than good
um
it depends
focusing on that
while ignoring what else is going on
does more harm than good
but pushing back on their [ __ ]
is almost always a good idea
that should not be the only thing that
you put your attention into because part
of their hope when they do this culture
War stuff is to distract from other
stuff they might be doing so you always
need to pay attention to what else is
going on that they're focusing on this
but you can't just let it go
unchallenged either
because much like any
um voice of intolerance
if you let it go unchallenged it
permeates so it does need to be
addressed doesn't need to be addressed
to an extent that we are ignoring you
know nuts and bolts actual policy that
they are trying to push through no but
at the same time these are often nested
subjects they're not mutually exclusive
so like when the right goes after queer
representation at the same time that
they are going after the actual rights
of queer people you can actually kind of
tackle that all in a bundle pretty
easily because it's all the same thing
if that makes sense
uh let's see
I finally saw everything everywhere all
at once really really liked it I'm glad
that's a really good really good show
is it true that Spider-Man isn't as
miserable in the comics as he is in the
movies
um depends on the era sometimes he is
for stretches he is he's not always like
there is the notorious Peter Parker look
he has the worst luck in the freaking
world like just bad stuff just happens
to him
Halloween isn't as big a thing in
Britain kids go for trick-or-treating
young people dress up and get hammered
the older crowd doesn't really care yeah
and so that's another reason that I
would be surprised if Doctor Who ever
did uh Halloween special as a regular
thing I've always had the opinion that
Disney remakes didn't have to be what
they are except Mulan you could have cut
Mushu and make the tone darker but kept
the tone but kept some of the comedy ah
oh Discord yeah sorry I'm sorry Carolyn
I was behind in the chat so I'm only now
uh seeing that reminder so I'll do that
in a second
like
unless it is a ground up
reinterpretation of the original myth I
don't know why artistically like money
is the answer but artistically I don't
know why you'd make any of those remakes
okay popping over to Discord
um back real quick
uh do you find writing Sprints to be
effective motivating tool sometimes
um I think the most important thing for
me is to get back into the habit of
setting aside time on a regular basis to
write which is something I have not done
for a while
but writing Sprints can help kind of
kick my ass to get me back in the habit
again if I've fallen out of it is what I
find do you ever find yourself wanting
to revisit media you were introduced to
because of a commissioned review
um sometimes excuse me and um sometimes
I have continued on with it like uh Doom
Patrol I was only commissioned for the
first two episodes and I finished the
first season I haven't gotten to the
other Seasons because I've got other
stuff I need to do but
um
oftentimes the simple reality with the
commission reviews is you know the the
commission makes me make time for it but
if I don't have something making me make
time for it most of the time even if
it's something that was intriguing I'm
like I've got other stuff I gotta do
uh are there any songs besides the ones
in the show that remind you of Doctor
Who yeah odd odd one but it really does
um
it is a
um
A Miracle of Sound song called into the
wild and it's actually about uh Zelda
breath of the Wild
but something about the vibe of it
feels Doctor Who to me
um let's see so you know how people keep
complaining about she-hulk's CGI and
asking if they can fix it
I've seen some people saying the same
thing in response to that they sat After
People complained about the original
Sonic animation basically guys of the
studio actually helps to fix it it'll
put the the VFX team under even more
crunch than they're probably already
under apparently Disney is especially
bad for slave driving VFX artists which
is most likely why She-Hulk looks not so
good in the first place
how do you feel about the idea it's bad
to complain about a product a company is
putting out if
fixing it would just create more work
for already uh overworked employees
so
I don't think I don't think that a
broken system is a reason to let a flaw
go on remarked on I do think that that
is a reason to not be a demanding prick
and be like you should fix this because
that will lead to even worse
circumstances but look if the work is
bad
I understand the circumstances under
which it was made but if the work is bad
we should say so because that as long as
we're not being asses about it that
might theoretically actually help
because if they if the system that this
work is being created under is bad and
we're all going it's bad maybe that's a
point of Leverage that can be used to
try and spur unionization and change of
the system if we say nothing and just
act like it's fine when it's not then
there's definitely no motivation to
change it so no I think bad CGI should
be noted it should be pointed out but
nobody should be demanding it be changed
or fixed because no that is potentially
damaging
I don't know where you live so maybe
hopefully this would be unlikely but
what would you do if a teacher at your
daughter's school starts spreading
anti-lgbtq propaganda to the kids a
while back another YouTuber who I won't
name for reasons unrelated to this made
a video where he talked about how a
teacher at his kids school started
telling the kids HIV was God punishing
the gays and when he complained nothing
happened because it was Georgia
[Laughter]
here's the thing
uh you push that nonsense on my kid
you try and demonize queerness to my kid
I will come down on you like a ton of
bricks I will write and call up and
email and pester
every relevant person whether it be the
school board the principal the local
newspaper whatever it takes I will use
my platform
to call you on your nonsense
I need
my child to be in an lgbtq plus safe
environment
and that's not me like out of my kid as
anything none of that is anybody's
business
so that's not even what I'm saying but I
need to know that if and when my kid
ever feels the need to come out as
anything that she knows she's safe
and I will burn some crap down
to ensure that it happens or to prevent
damage from being done
do not mess with my kid
ever
moving on suppose an actor transition
then expressed a desire for people not
to watch their pre-transition content
but their pre-transition filmography
included some pretty important films
what would you do I was thinking of this
because I know Contra points doesn't
like people watching your pre-transition
videos which got me thinking what should
we do if uh a really famous trans actor
felt that way I honestly don't know
um I think it it's it is a little bit
different with an online content creator
because Contra points uh has complete
control over her content it is her
decision alone to take something down
for that reason and ultimately while the
rest of us may lose the ability to
re-engage with that content it affects
uh basically nobody but her
um I don't know what my thoughts would
be on that I think
I would be very surprised if an actor if
a trans actor actually made that request
publicly I wouldn't be shocked if some
of them felt that way and like certainly
don't want to talk about their
pre-transition work or something like
that I'd be surprised if they ever
expressed that outright because it is
it would I'm not going to say it
definitively is this but it would likely
be perceived as
um
them
[Music]
shutting down everybody else's
contributions like nobody should watch
this movie because I was
pre-transitioned well nobody else
involved in that movie knew that and
you're saying that nobody should enjoy
their work either do you have the right
to do that
certainly not by force do you have the
right to request that well I mean you
can request whatever you like but I
think
I don't think it would go down well as a
public relations thing if somebody tried
which is probably why even if some feel
that way I'd be surprised if it ever
gets said out loud if that makes sense
um do you feel that a certain kind of
pandering to a very narrow fan base
hobbles the work like with the recent
Star Wars Trilogy as a hypothetical
example
I'm not sure that works as an example
because I'm not sure that was actually
properly pandering like the
pandering is a really hard thing to pull
apart because there's good panda and
there's bad panda and what is what
generally is going to be dictated by
whether or not you are part of the
audience is pandering to so it's a
difficult thing to like
to my way of thinking
the narrower a a an audience you are
pandering to the smaller the project
should be if you are making a big
project spending a lot of money on it
and it needs to be accessible to a
massive swath of people to ever make its
money back
you should not be pandering to a very
narrow or Niche audience that's just
or if you're going to do that you should
go in knowing that you were never going
to get the chance to do that again like
either shoot your shot and go all in
um but if you ever want to keep doing
that that's a bad idea
uh would a retracting of some kind of of
some of the movie properties in Marvel
ease some of the genre creep uh that
some are accusing the MCU of
um
I don't think I'm familiar enough with
what the criticism of genre creep of the
MCU is uh and if it if genre creep is
what I think it is it's not a criticism
I share or really understand
at this point like
some of these things are nation and more
Niche genres so freaking what
uh
when is a good time to Kill Your
Darlings before they get love bombed
into saying something stupid or is that
an an individual choice
um
so the way you worded that is really
weird because Kill Your Darlings is a
term
um usually meant to apply to your
creative Works don't be precious about
your uh Creations be willing to do
whatever's best even if that means
killing an idea but then you
were then you worded the second half in
a way that makes it sound like you're
referring to like your kids
and
if and then you lost me so I don't
I don't know how to engage with that
question
I mean the the answer to any question
about raising kids at all is it varies
from person to person people will make
their own calls and I'm not here to I'm
not a parent I have no uh I have no
business
critiquing
anyone's General parenting technique
specific things parents do I may
critique if I feel it is relevant for me
to do so
thoughts on Sony trying to make Tarzan
into a movie a major movie franchise
again they are desperate aren't they
it'd be funny if it wasn't so pathetic
do you think the alien France saw and
France good grief do you think the alien
franchise could or should try to
experiment more with alien species that
aren't just the Xenomorphs given the
fact that the title of the series is
pretty nebulous no I think they should
stop making alien movies
stop just stop there's nothing left to
do stop walk away stop just stop stop
doing it
people always use vampires and
werewolves and we have seen massive
surges of series using them but why do
you think we have yet to get a
Frankenstein craze well because
Frankenstein as a monster by his nature
is unique by their nature vampires and
werewolves can be many and take many
shapes and be many things and not
require a unique origin for each one
they have a generic origin bitten by a
vampire bitten by a werewolf
Frankenstein's they require a creator
and even if you don't do the literals
um
sewing together of dead bodies like
that's at the core of what Frankenstein
and yes I know Frankenstein was the
doctor not the monster we all know what
I'm talking about don't be a patent so
like the idea of what Frankenstein is
requires you to cover where that thing
came from and
the the something that lends itself to a
craze is usually something that's a lot
more malleable
you don't have as much Freedom working
with Frankenstein as a as a starting
base premise other than like just to be
like something really Bonkers with it
but it kind of all Roots back to the
same story like you can you can tell a
vampire story and not have to have it be
like Dracula you can tell a werewolf
story and not have to have a bee like
the Wolfman
but there's only so far you can get from
the Frankenstein story while dealing
with a Frankenstein monster
I think that's part of the problem it's
it's limiting as a concept I think it's
part of the same reason that we have not
seen uh nearly as many
equivalents to Creature from the Black
Lagoon in addition to the fact that it's
a
it's a full body prosthetic and
difficult to make work
uh I'm almost done with the Discord and
then I'll pop back on for like 10
minutes or something to catch up with
the chat
um do you think the BBC will remember to
tell us the date of the Centenary
special part of the dogs before it
actually airs I think we do have an air
date I think we have that or at least
there is a um expected air date maybe
it's not confirmed hang on
power of the doctor
air date
uh no I guess we still don't have it
it's still speculative
it's this month
I guess it's still not official
there's okay so there is
some are saying it'll be Sunday the 23rd
some have it earlier than that
um
that is unconfirmed
it I'm I'm double checking
uh
yeah they still have not announced the
official air date
son of a what
what are they doing
what are they doing
I'm so confused
because they're trading the Centenary
special like like they're trying to dump
it so no one will notice but at the same
time they're doing a lot of Doctor Who
stuff in the future so it's not like
they're scrapping the IP and putting it
on ice
what are they doing
oh my God
oh my God
huh
Aniston Jason Lee Garner Hudson Love
Hewitt best and worst Jennifer's I
I don't have enough of an opinion on any
of them to rank them interesting
question I don't have an answer
uh four live-action Star Wars shows done
and forthcoming in the works when does
it become too much of a good thing
simply because of volume for the
non-hardcore fan well for me it's
already too much
for me like I I'm so grateful that I
like Andor as much as I do because
um I am burnt out on Star Wars in
general and Andor I mean Obi-Wan Kenobi
was a little bit of a breath of fresh
air but Andor is great and thank
goodness because if I didn't like Andor
I might have to walk away from Star Wars
as a whole but a whole bunch of the
announced stuff I have like zero
interest in I have no interest in Ahsoka
I have no interest in whatever the Old
Republic whatever they're doing I just I
don't I don't care it is too much yeah I
and like anyone who feels that way about
Marvel at this point I get it because
I'm already there with Star Wars okay
I'm back in the main chat now
so I know I've got some super chats that
I had not
gotten to yet so I'm prioritizing those
I know I'm skipping over a lot of other
stuff there's no way I'm going to catch
up
Supreme Omega while it's easy to blame
the infamous clone saga for spidey's 90s
troubles I feel it first started to go
wrong when Peter's robot parents Arc
happened uh that certainly didn't help
and even the clone saga wasn't bad
initially they just stretched it out for
freaking years when it was originally
intended to be like a six month story
so
overindulgence is the word of the 90s
when it comes to the comics
and what's the other we got a couple of
other super chats John vinyls thank you
very much I like Imagining the owl house
done in the animation style of Over the
Garden Wall because they have the same
New England fairy tale Vibe ooh
that could work
that could certainly work oh I should
pencil in a re-watch of that for October
for myself
oh maybe I can get Liz to watch it well
maybe I get the kiddo to watch it
we tried we tried a little while back
she didn't go for it but that was like
three years ago she probably doesn't
remember
ooh Maybe
maybe I gotta try that
um anyways
let me see here
uh John vinyls once again thank you so
much Toff is another example of gergy
syndrome in that she does not fit the
tone of
um avatar The Last Airbender at all
instead being a snarky Millennial
teenager plopped into the middle of a
classic fantasy Quest story so
uh I haven't really talked about tough
because I didn't I ultimately while I
watched basically all of the second uh
season of Avatar I didn't do a review of
it because my
um
oh I missed a couple of questions at the
top of the Discord oh
oh you're right I did so hold on I'll
pop back to that in a second let me deal
with this question with this question
first so
um
I remember when I did my review of the
first season a lot of people told me
like oh it's okay you'll like
um
uh I like you know you'll like season
two oh wait till you meet tough and then
I'm at Toff
then like Toff
I get why some people would but she did
nothing for me and honestly my issue
with her was like she's just like the
most negative person she's just grumpy
about everything or sarcastic about
everything I'm like you have no joy in
life
I don't want to spend time with you
so I think it's interesting to compare
it with a distinctly annoying character
like gergy but I can see how the tonal
Clash could be an issue for some okay so
I missed a couple of Discord questions
so popping back right there do you enjoy
horror movies there's a horror movie
about capitalism called the platform
that I thought you might be interested I
have not heard of that horror movies for
me I am very picky I enjoy monster
movies I rarely enjoy slashers I enjoy
ghost movies I'm not a Gore Hound I
appreciate horror Aesthetics a lot more
than most horror stories I find most
horror stories are
often very flimsy and serve as excuses
for something be the excuses for
gratuitous kills creative violence what
have you and if that's what you're here
for that's fine but I need a decent
story and characters on top of that so
I'm very picky with horror movies uh and
I missed one others
um I remember you saying you were going
to do an undertale review are you still
planning on it
I thought I'd done it
I thought I did it
um carowind actually alerted me to this
question before the stream and I went
and double checked and I'm like no I
never did
I could have sworn like I must have
gotten buried under other stuff that I
needed to do and I just forgot
I assumed that I had but no you're right
I haven't that's I've got that penciled
in to try and get to this month now
um so anyways uh what else have I got
uh
oh
there's the oh 255 A.D thank you very
much for the Super Chat there's the
Fairly Odd Parents episode where Timmy
accidentally pushes himself into a girl
for a day what would the reaction to the
episode be today
well
if you're asking well my reaction would
be I don't know I would have to see it
um
I uh so here's the first thing
given what we now know about the general
leanings and attitude about the guy who
was the creator of Fairly Odd Parents
um if that was done today it would be
probably really transphobic
um but if however as it was done at the
time if it was done now if Timmy's
reaction was at any point anything other
than utter revulsion a hundred percent
of the time it would be called woke
propaganda by right-wing pundits it just
would
uh
okay
what about mummies mummies again they
they are usually a unique thing
um I mean like in video games you'll
have groups of mummies but you know I I
I think again
it's because it's all wrapped up in the
like the curse the mummy's curse again
it's a it's a much more restrictive kind
of template
and plus like you're just not gonna get
better than mummy on the Orient Express
so like everybody can pack it in now
uh something I've been thinking about is
uh what would Steven Universe be like if
they redid it in the tone and design of
something like Castlevania
wow
that'd be
that would be a trip I kind of want to
see like a test reel of that now
comedian Russell Howard put the
religious argument about homosexuality
uh and the and the weather best in
ancient Greece all they did was read and
blank each other and the weather was
lovely
hahaha
nice
Emma Caufield has confirmed that her one
division character is returning for
Agatha Harkness
uh she also revealed she's been battling
multiple sclerosis oh geez all right
that's a bummer be very curious to see
what they do with that character
uh question have you ever seen Archer if
not I can't recommend enough uh I can
quote most of the episodes verbatim if
I'm using the term uh right I might just
love Archer I've seen I forget how many
seasons I've seen four or five seasons
of Archer
I've seen through like the first
um
like uh out of continuity one the um the
one that was the detective story was
Dreamland something like that I saw
through that and actually I think I even
saw the one after that the one on the
island
I think that's all I I think that's
everything I've seen though
but yeah I enjoy I enjoy
I enjoy Archer
uh
yeah I'm horny for Archer phrasing
sorry that was the like that was the
joke that came to my mind for some
reason I should wrap it up
um uh we went a little uh over time
um but
I think I'm think I'm ready to to wrap
it up there uh I'm out of water
so we're gonna call it a night uh thank
you everybody for joining me
um thank you for your time this is fun
this is
this is always fun
I enjoyed this a lot so thank you very
much and
um I hope that you have a great rest of
the day hope you have a great rest of
the month hope you're back in two weeks
for the watch along of morbius it'll be
morbidden time
um and in the meantime I hope that you
remember that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you're the council I just run these
wacky meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
Kennedy
I didn't end it right away oh I was
supposed to do it mid